just fell over
hi everyone it's happy
happy happy podcast um
uh it's my we film on mondays
this is monday after super bowl super
bowl
monday how do you feel super bowl monday
uh i feel
i don't watch football almost at all
i don't think i've watched more than i
watched the super bowl
yeah of course um and uh
people were talking about how the game
sucked game wasn't great it wasn't a
great game
i don't know how good the game like i
thought about the game at the end with
seattle and the
past and the internet like they can't
all be that no they're not all gonna be
that but
they're not always a blowout either it
didn't
the thing with the super bowl is it
never feels like a blowout because it's
so
like ah over there and then this guy
and then over like this guy's hurt and
then him
and it really there's so much garbage
going on that
you never think i should turn this off
it really
i because the commercials are part
part of the thing now right and when i
say now i mean the last 25 years
um i remember when they weren't um the
commercials are such a big part that you
just
it's like worth watching if you're a
football fan
the blood is a little it just it feels a
lot more lackluster
than yeah
as an event i didn't find it especially
good
any better or worse than i normally find
it i felt bad for my homes
i know like it just felt like
uh it felt like a star
in a shitty movie yeah just like oh [ __ ]
that's that scene that scene's over like
he couldn't
he got no help anywhere and um
and the and you know and the brady thing
is
i guess you root for him why
how do you because he's old wait what in
what sense
in the game or just because just as a
story
like the old guy he that somebody
pointed out he got
fired by new england basically new
england was like you're too old we're
done
and he that's what happened basically
yeah uh they
i thought they had issues with like um
the uh
what's his name that jimmy no no like he
they wanted
some sort of like someone to start
as a quarterback you're fired he's fired
we want the young kid it's a good story
like we want the young kid and he's like
i've got a lot left in the tank like
hell you do
i'm going to florida and then he goes to
florida and he
wins the uh the the championship
in that sense it's definitely good yes
and he's going to give a lot of guys in
their 40s the courage to go out and blow
out their knees
and tear their acls and you're going to
in in
three weeks you're going to see a lot of
old dudes on crutches because they tore
their
their achilles tendons trying to do
something they shouldn't have been doing
um and and you didn't like
particularly love any of the commercials
i
didn't like you none of them were
it i it felt like super bowl is a is a
once a year where famous people go
and [ __ ] up their legacies for money
just hey you want to come and
bomb so much people i'm
i'm ashton kutcher four million
okay it wasn't me
no that's how we should have done it
well no
the problem was why was that so [ __ ]
the promise
he should not have sang
he should not have sang and they should
have done
a version
and if you need to auto tune it auto
tune it
yeah auto tune might have made it
funnier yes
with him singing it yes it would have
made it bearable
because it was almost unbearable
it was the longest 60 seconds of my life
i would um
yeah i that was the longest 60 seconds
what do you think you got paid for it
because it was
i think he got four
i think he got i think they probably
split
six is what i think
so yeah that's where we go that bad geez
no it's you're getting good money
levine adam levine called me when he was
on his way to his and i
i guess what he made did you guess right
yes i heard they don't i heard the
performers do they they don't get paid
is that right who the performers the
weekend didn't doesn't get paid
why does the weekend not get paid in
advance that's just one thing
uh this is one of them because it's good
it's good pr
it's just good no they you don't get
paid
i mean not uh it's like hosting the
oscars you don't get
oh it's like you get a hundred grand you
don't get you get
for showbiz it's not a lot of money it's
just like here
um but like if ashton if
mila and ashton are splitting six or
eight
and the weekend's getting nothing
there's not there's no justice but
we all know that we can can be in a
commercial next year
yeah and make the money it was just
there's so many bad commercials but i
don't like
buy the celebrity camera i mean i get
because it
moves the needle for the chairman
the chairman goes what are we doing my
kids love them yeah
and then you go hey i got so-and-so
and then it feels like something and you
can show it at your
a lot of times they'll buy you not only
will the star do a commercial they have
to do like
two live events for the company uh where
they just have to show up and be like
hey
or sing or whatever whatever they do
um break dance whatever they're known
for
and um so there's like
it's a package and the other thing is
you immediately forgot the commercials
yeah they have
like drakes and uh drake was in the
state farm commercial barely remember
and he i bet he made more than anybody
even though he had one line he well he
was in a lot of the car i mean he had
like more lines than
rudd did yeah i remember a couple years
ago rudd had
a bud light an ant-man and an acura
and made must have made 10 million
dollars
i had to um
so but the the the reason they don't
work and i was explaining before we
started rolling
they put in too many jokes
they they don't they're so worried about
covering like we gotta get to this
person and that person and that gag and
that
that there's no pace at all to
i did one last year with john and
chrissy and
chrissy was [ __ ] on rich people and
it's
too fast for the jokes to read yeah and
i told them and they didn't care
um and john and chrissy get so much
money that
they didn't really care either the
ending was cute
open the door save sexist man alive
ta-da
and nice and it worked for the company
they blew out the website
the computers were smoking um but
in terms of like a an artistic endeavor
it's basically
hello celebrity come ruin people's
memories of you
for money um or yeah
who what's i like the lemons one the
lemon
lemonade one oh yeah that was good
yeah it's funny you're right i don't i'm
like it's
starting to feel it's like a dream yes
it's like a dream you you don't
you don't you're like what i was like
the other lemon
commercials in and of themselves are
hard to remember
i actually remember a lot of commercials
well
i remember a lot thinking is they have
to air it eight to ten times before
anyone ever
yeah uh like people still are just
seeing my chase commercial
it's like yeah it's been a long time
um if they're really good or really like
if they fall in the middle obviously we
don't remember like my choice commercial
go ahead
is that really good or really bad um no
but if they're bad i remember them too
so it's just if they're infamous or good
you were saying that you don't like the
serious ones
i hate the i hate them so much i don't
understand why not
because it feels like
uh it's so manufactured pulling at your
heartstrings
there's a google one like years ago that
the person was just
googling life-changing things how to
buy a car how to go on a date how to
propose
and it's just like shut the f it i i
hate it it's so cheap i also don't like
rom-coms
at all i hate them very much
so i just i hate manufactured
like oh yeah like or you know we got
dads dude like handheld refugees dust
deportations fences always there's like
a you surprise your adult mom
with her right [ __ ] tricycle from
19 i don't i don't like it i'm tearing
up about
it she may not like it but i'm hello
hello advertising
i've got a hit um
well the bigger issue is it's hard to
know what they're about until the end
no that's what you said yes because if
they're good they can't
really be about if they're good and then
it's like oh beer
like beer yeah beer yeah yeah
they're always like beer and family
like beer no amir pointed out on twitter
like
the the one that maya rudolph was in no
idea what that was for
yeah none or the one with all the
celebrities there's a bunch of different
that's for paramount huh that's for the
new paramount streaming one where's like
patrick stewart and
james corden yes colbert yeah that's for
paramount
um yeah everything is it's a hard
transition with the softies
that i didn't mind the paramount one no
that one was actually the most
fun because it was like oh i wanna i'll
i want this
it's a good i like when they do
realistic representations of a
like a channel and everyone's there um
it's fun
uh so that and that made me actually
wanna get the channel
do you because you do a lot of
commercial directing do you pay
attention to
shut up do you pay attention to
commercials
or no yeah of course yeah like are you
like that was a good one
well i like you doing sketches because
you do it with sketches and comedy stuff
yeah i mean the thing with commercials
is they don't
the chances are they're not going to
work what about geico
they're really hit and miss there guy
you know
the one with tracy morgan got the
highest rated
which one the one from last night oh
really you know it was the number one
rated one
of the they ranked them and i watched it
was like that's six jokes that
should have worked and didn't like they
just none of them popped
right it was just like uh
it's true because i didn't get enough of
the tracy morgan i wanted and then i
watched the
decent did you ever see his jesus and
marrow interview no
that's three maniacs that's maniac on
maniac
he out maniacs them to their speech
that's his whole thing
it's so good anyways but uh yeah
that one was okay yeah but that's all it
takes
uh i watched what do i watch them for i
gotta say i don't really watch them
any differently than anybody else i'm
not like i like the way
i mean like i i could tell all the like
on the paramount one i'll be like oh
this is pretty good green screen
meaning like they're none of them are
together obviously yeah
i did think there was a wide shot in the
paramount one
where i was like that's a hard wide to
get
i love it that's it and the reason it's
a hard wide to get is because you have
to
take a guy who gives you no time
to colbert anybody whoever anybody in
the commercial
and go stand over there and we're going
to film you from
80 yards away and then their next
thought is [ __ ] get a stand-it
right but you're like yeah we could have
and they probably did
in truth but it's hard to get wides
because you don't want the person to be
like
somebody told me a story about johnny
depp doing a
michael mann movie uh like public enemy
and at one point michael mann
michael mance like you know a real
artist and at some point
he was shooting the back of johnny
depp's head for 45 minutes and finally
johnny that was like
come on man it's the [ __ ] back of my
head just get somebody else
my head's not that unique but that's the
only reason
that's what i watch for but then you
think about it let's just take mila
ashton kutcher if they split six million
dollars
[ __ ] you're gonna stand all god
i would think no i know that's not how
it is at all
but you'd think standing so someone can
block
and figure out your light let's just say
an
extra half a day's work would be
there so much how long commercials
should take
lebron i this i don't know come down
here peasants that film commercials i've
heard
again this is like what tell me i heard
lebron when he did space jam was
surprised how long [ __ ] took
yeah and it's like yeah yeah you kind of
you remember on the sprite commercial
i we had to it was an
extra day of just planning the day how
could i
forget yeah or co any one of these
commercials i get three hours of be i
had to go in and tell kobe the rundown
of the day i was like
okay at 9 45 you're gonna sit down
that's where they're now
10 o'clock you're gonna i'm gonna bring
you into makeup
10 30 you're gonna get your photos taken
um so when they have to do real [ __ ]
in celebrities defense there's a
depending on the director
a lot of time wasted on those sets yes
i'm like why does this does not need to
take yeah why are there so many people
why is this taking so long why does it
cost so much
and i still think that it's crazy i'm
just like
this doesn't need to take this long
someone's lollygagging for
decades it's not you can only
the whole thing is about lighting yeah
so it's just how long does it take
to set up lights that's it yeah lights
and walls
moving lights and walls you can only do
it so quickly
i mean then again in my back in the
golden era they would
film a movie in 20 days yes
and they all looked like plays they look
good they look good
they all look like pl they all look like
our podcast
every conversation it's a wall and like
let me tell you something
cut to a close-up i'll tell you
something you're going to hell
and i'll tell you why you're going to
hell there was no there's almost no
there's movement in like three scenes
there's movement on establishing shots
because there's no stars in them um so
i know i remember when we were on the
the sprite commercial
uh it was the weirdest
i lebron gets this but you guys don't
one guy was feeling had to fill back up
our sprite like glassware
glass bottle with water uh i found out
on the corona commercial i just did that
the they use the they use different
glass
for the hero bottle
it's hand blown and it would go on did
not know that
don't know the sprites were hand blown
also they were not
uh they look like just like mexican coke
bottles you know
uh like squirt anyways it was right but
so
one guy would just fill it back up with
his hands
and with lebron's he would go and put on
gloves
and i was like well wait wait a minute i
don't want
the ungl just it was like
uh oh taco for lebron hold this spit
like no wait do the glove thing for me
and i
i was like excuse me i'm susceptible to
um shepherd
you literally said that i am i'm really
susceptible
though i was like that is you about
white girl yourself
for the white girl awards that's
absolutely up
that's on the short list for the
nomination i catch you start going to
luncheons where you promote your work
i i people need to wash their hands i
was like well let me
i susceptible did the guy go well it's a
hundred degrees out
right now we're in the valley it's
august that's not as strong that works
what
well it was september it was 100 degrees
though anyways
needless to say he was like let me not
embarrass neil
yeah you know i invited you you're my
guest my special guest
that was my that was graft i mean that's
just corruption
didn't have to audition yeah maybe you
didn't i [ __ ] auditioned twice
a lot of hardship i'm sorry but you're
susceptible i am
sorry you're worse is that you didn't
say that at the audition i don't
remember that
um now so super ball
obviously rest in power king and um
commercials rest in power uh even the
one with cedric
and post malone total waste of all those
people
it didn't even make it's like what in
the [ __ ] is this
what is this you don't even know you
don't can't you you have to figure out
like what are you guys going for
okay the car the party one was fine the
which one cardio was okay
uh kind of kind of that felt like a
better use of yes it was
a good first of all i just wanted to say
mike myers is one of the greats of all
time
and um i remember when i saw wayne's
world in the theater
as uh the premiere as a film film
student young film student
i walked out and said that's the best
movie i've ever seen and i still kind of
believe that
how good wayne's world is williamsworld
or two one two was great though
it was so good yeah but uh
yeah carney wasn't bad the the thing
that made me laugh actually laughed was
the baby
uh oh the babies was [ __ ] funny they
were
and it's a call back to a joke that they
did in wayne's world
about like i would never sell out right
right that's windral too
when he's like this pill no there's this
advil little yellow different is from
the first one
oh advil little yellow and i was like
what the [ __ ] are they doing in this and
it was unbelievable yeah it's so funny
little yellow different those
covers i have uh do you like those
commercials
which i don't remember
uh what love wayne's world
read the script for austin powers and
was like this is [ __ ] genius
was up to direct the love guru ooh
met with mike myers at his house and
uh within five minutes
he did the walk behind the couch thing
like and i was like this is [ __ ]
unbelievable
and why didn't you go why didn't i
direct the movie yeah
uh uh
did it didn't work out okay
moving on didn't work out um
now can you feel um
can you feel black history month can you
feel it i feel it
does it feel any different my blood your
black blood
racial equality inclusion blood hole um
can you put the link to the people keep
hitting me up for it
uh they'll i don't think there is a link
is there i send you a link google drive
oh all right yeah put it up there just
put it it seems like we're doxing
somebody but [ __ ] what's the thing
yeah it is a thing look look it's there
we didn't make him do that actually no
but it's
whatever um
southern playalistic a delica music
it's i swear i think it's only just like
active listening feelers that want to
listen to the whole thing i don't think
it's anybody that's like just don't be
mean
just listening it would be funny if
white people had to talk like this for
all of february
that would be that would be so goddamn
funny
uh if every white person had to speak
like a black yeah
uh the south still got something to say
um um uh it's it i know
i wrote it down and you wrote it down
too what's your target
you're a target sorry can you google
black history
month target t-shirts when you see the
t-shirts that they came up with
is it the highest logo is there a serve
to highlight
in the crosstalk damn i should have gave
you a link will sorry about that
um
[Music]
yeah that seems all right and it shows
all of them and they're
they're rough uh
so basically let me um let me it's all
the
that was all the black employees from
target
um so the shirts are
bad really do they take them down bad
they're
backlash bad but not take them down
maybe don't do that we can just
read the title read some of the titles
uh
yes just yes yes there's
there are worse ones hype me sis
up well up
mess in a bottle working on my mess
that's a baby shirt yeah to my black
people i love you it's like
okay you going down to the men's ones
let's see
they keep saying mess in a bottle
there's some that are
they're so don't let what you've been
through distort what you see that one's
like
that one's like huh that's a little
complicated for a t-shirt
furthermore um
we are yeah i don't i don't like them
i'll say that i'm not going to wear them
sorry ida maya they have the thing of
like malcolm harriet
langston okay they stole that like
and and and thing t-shirt earth thing
black bulk er
thing shortened blk earthing black
everything or anything um uh
some of them are just like could you
have
put more effort it's like
these corporations were cornered it's
like they're in a corner and they're
like
hey hey i'm cool i got a earthing black
t-shirt
would a racist have that how about this
mess in a bottle i got a mess and a
bottle t-shirt because they're in
minneapolis so they still think black
people were coming for them
like yeah they're like hey hey we're
cool look at this
huh uh you good
you good question mark
just poof it's just embarrassing it's
just
i what corporations seem to not
understand is they don't need to do this
this one is the worst racism tried to
steal my joy period
ha exclamation point tried
what eat your greens colored green i
don't know i just
think are you talking to me now are you
just reading t-shirts
it's a um embarrassment and
it's worse than any super bowl ad
i know it's gonna say okay would you
take all these shirts or
or mila and ashton it wasn't me on your
art you know
they they used to
they show guys at guantanamo bay the
milan ashton
commercial instead of waterboarding and
they've given up a lot of secrets let me
just tell you right now
20 year old secrets um
yeah i i they don't need to do this
and it started i mean it didn't start
it got significantly worse during george
floyd
the corporate like hey oh now it's just
the lgbt
pride month we're cool
and but this [ __ ] is unbearable this is
when it got it got
worse it used to be like aggravating and
embarrassing
and then george floyd made it horrific
um and uh that's where we are
and i would say to the many corporations
listening
uh quit it just give money to black
people
just give money to black charities and
by the way mackenzie bezos who we
talked about mckenzie whatever scott is
her name uh
her thing is she just gives money to
charities and doesn't say what to do
with it
they can't even respond to her great
yeah
which everyone's pointing out like this
is what it should be just
here take the money you guys know what
to do with it i don't care what you do
with it
cause guess what i didn't earn it
right i didn't deserve i don't deserve
this it's cartoon money
yeah um the
yeah i heard for black history month um
pep boys
manny moe and jack are gonna uh change
it to
malcolm martin and bernie mac that's
just what i heard
first of all how do you know their name
on jack
and they're malcolm malcolm martin and
mack um
and other corporations
[Music]
apple released an ad that said our
screens are black for a reason
no they didn't oh
hellman's mayonnaise released an ad that
said um
even though black people don't like us
we like black people so
they're all trying bianca i'm doing a
desk piece without
it's like i have a tv show not i don't
these are just
ones i've thought of over the days uh
so cut it out right just cut it out you
don't got to do this just give money to
blind people or hire black people or
something or don't
like don't tell security not to follow
black people around
until march 1st yeah make policies make
great policies don't need the t-shirts
and also you know who makes money off of
t-shirts
target um so anyhow
uh covet is still around bianca
what yeah that old [ __ ] yeah
um you have israel written down what did
you want to say
they got the dang cure well oh you're
talking about the second the other one
when something came out last night
i this was a few days ago but it's
basically
um they found a way to it's it's uh
it's like a respiratory medicine so you
breathe it in so people who were
moderate
and severe all 30 30
all went home all were covered within
three to five days 29
out of 30 and then the the it was the
thirtieth recovered
but it just took a week it took longer
yes they did most of them take three to
five days
and it basically i didn't realize this
but there's a kind of
immune response storm that happens which
is maybe
cytokines cytokinesis that is basically
responsible for what kills people it's
just
an overreaction of your immune system so
it has cured all the severe patients
which is just a nice it's in phase one
yeah they're doing it in greece now
they're like uh
they're testing it out in greece and
seeing like what the results are there
it's just i it just it's nice that
there's
everyone is still trying to solve this
thing i
agree it feels like vaccine boom
i have a theory i have a few theories
okay by the way they did a study
jimmy carr sent me a link with
the with in quotes they did a study
and the study was he is the funniest
comedian
they literally did a study where they
they which i've always wanted to do
20 comedians who gets the most laughs
per minute
the who gets the biggest laughs from the
most people per minute
is that the was that the measure yes and
jimmy's style lends itself to that
yeah but it's still got to feel pretty
good um
congratulations congratulations jimmy
carr we made you a podcast
um okay here's my
a couple theories about covent come on
coven
did i tell you about have i i talked so
much
do i did i tell you about the war of the
worlds theory
no okay remember where the world's the
stephen spielberg one that came out in
like 2002
i didn't see it but yes right tim
robbins a bunch of people
the end of it is spoiler alert
the end of there's like the big battle
and then there's just a post script that
says like
in the spring it went away
it's the weirdest [ __ ] ending it was
like wait what what
what like it it was awful
but i something tells me if we can get
it in front of
all these the the new ones
um the reboots um
i feel like it's just gonna we're gonna
wake up not one day but it's going down
like
five percent a day at this point and i
feel like at a certain point we're gonna
there's gonna be less than five thousand
people a day hospitalized like in may or
something
yeah that's the well according to my
model
if they if we get the vaccines going
it said like very little coveted in the
summer but that's
excludes variants that excludes variants
the
south african one and the british one
that that
or assumes that moderna and
and uh pfizer can take it on
right or johnson johnson which
apparently one of them johnson johnson
no no no no
it's the azure seneca yeah that one
they stopped the vaccines in south
africa because it wasn't working
they throw them all in the ocean
apparently
um yeah so so
i feel like what you feel i first of all
i'd also like to say
as much as people are complaining about
how it's the rollout was
it's [ __ ] kind of amazing how many
vaccines are giving out
they're giving up between a million and
two million a day now
on even including like saturday i don't
know how they did it wow
saturday they gave up 1.9 million which
you know i don't know
what does that mean it means that
they're giving out vaccines
on weekends which some place they're not
open on the weekends
a lot of places some place that give
them out from what i hear are not open
on the weekends
um so uh i'm like to say i'm impressed
to the government if you're listening
government good job
and it's only gonna get better are you
are you are you impressed enough to help
out your boy newsome because
things are going down in california yeah
but i uh
that's the point my point about newsome
is
uh based on his rollout of everything
based on how he handled good man
lockdowns and all that [ __ ] is
it was uh not it was unwinnable
in essence 100 he was and
they're just mad at him because he's
good looking and he went to dinner that
night
he they're very mad about french laundry
but
i mean this is a campaign that started
like by like
they're always yeah like they all
they're always trying to but they got
they are going to get the votes to have
a a recall yeah and he's going to get re
he's not going to get
kicked out i really and it's going to be
a total waste of time and we're all
gonna have to go vote
i'm absentee all day like i you can make
it so you're always absentee
neil participate that means you're part
of just means you don't have to go to a
boat you still vote
oh yeah you just mail it yeah yeah
that's what i mean what did you think i
meant
i don't know i for some reason i just
thought you meant you thought it was
like an absentee dab where i was
like i was in the puerto vallarta where
i couldn't be found
um and i tell the government yeah i'm
gonna vote i'll be up there tuesday and
i never show
i go wait for me in the parking lot and
then i don't show
um but the what i will
also say third fully is
the while the government has to be
cautious like science has to be cautious
has to be
there's got to be some incentive for
getting
vaccinated because at this point they're
like even when you get vaccinated
you're still you can still give it to
people so you gotta say
it's like [ __ ] then why would i
bother right like there's gotta be some
incentive like
i had the thought today first of all
this is separate but they should
connect in order to get vaccine
there should be a powerball they should
combine them
so if you want to play this powerball
it's 300 million dollars
you want in you got to get vaccinated it
automatically goes up
the amount of people that want the vax
automatically goes up they've made it so
you can only the reason i bring it up is
because they made it
so it's only worth getting vaccinated if
we reach herd immunity
otherwise be just as worried as you are
now
because it's not a hundred percent
thorough we don't even know if it does
if if you're if it um
transmission for the vaccinated
after 10 days the first shot it's
two-thirds less
they're positive of that that was in
their study
but they they but they make it so hard
to find yeah
and they make it i know i was sort of
like no
40 you're only 35 after the first one
there's so much yeah there's so many
numbers to the point where
i'm like i was telling somebody it feels
like i'm in the marines we're like [ __ ]
you
put a mask on you're like all right
they're like it's got to be flushing
your face you're like okay
sorry sorry sorry um can i get
vaccinated not [ __ ] yet [ __ ]
um so they gotta do better with
making it attractive because they just
make it like
it's your duty and it doesn't help what
doesn't help but you gotta do it what
about if they paid everyone
50 bucks a pop well that would be yeah
that'd be great it would be 1.5 trillion
dollars
no 1.5 billion which at this point
were made of money apparently uh be 1.5
billion
that's virtually nothing in america to
the american
government we're in so much debt now
whatever yeah [ __ ] it um which
the whole other thing about the people
who don't want
the checks the stimulus i want to yell
at them like
you know it's your money that's what i
don't i mean
it's it's either you we're in someone
said it's hard to know but it's
all coming out of our taxes why wouldn't
you want them to give you that money
i said that to that exact same argument
so we almost rarely get a return
on our like i mean most of our money
does go to defense most of our money
goes to certain things so this is one
that's actually coming right back to you
in a time of need why are you
upset well you know why because brown
people are getting and all of it
yeah it's like no free loaders yeah i'm
not a freeload now i'm different
for these brownies all the brownies
uh yes so they gotta incentivize it
because it's gotta be there's gotta be a
point
to i'm not saying if you get vaccinated
you shouldn't have to wear a mask but
i'm kind of saying that
like it because otherwise that would be
so right i know
that's then there's a whole thing of
it's like
and we don't and why should i
what do you someone got mad at me for
from my prisoner's point
what prison about like i'm a little on
the fence about prisoners getting it
before people
yeah um it's furious lost a listener
come back they didn't like baby i'm sure
they didn't leave anyone feeling um they
just wanted to get mad
um the
you've got uh
okay what do you think of
first world countries all having all the
backs and third world countries not
and what do you think we sh you should
do about it
um it's one of those it's one of the
things where
am i supposed to solve this problem no i
know i want a just world and i want
i believe in justice and then [ __ ] like
that happens and i'm like you know what
i'm
i don't something in me isn't flaring up
to stop this
it's what it's basically turns all of
america into white people
what white people in america are america
is in the rest of the world
and no one's going like this is wrong we
gotta get i mean
the wokest of the wokar but they're not
there's not much of a movement behind we
need to evenly distribute these vaccines
out to the entire world
no no person should come before another
person
it's like oh yeah you know technically
you know
just world this is a good way to start
there's not there's no equipment
yeah people don't care which is now
you're white people welcome welcome to
white
now just remember you are susceptible to
strep throat
since you're a white person a couple
things you should know you're
susceptible to strep throat
and etc etc
um little uzi vert
got a diamond in his forehead thereby
um finishing his conversion to
cartoon villain he already had that he
had the name where he's on the news
right where he's like
right right um this this guy is uh
a genuine weirdo yeah like that's
you don't that's automatically
uh on the on the admissions form
for the mental hospital did you put a
diamond
in your forehead yes come right this way
we have some medicine for you uh like
there's no way
you can be healthy
and do that well what do you think about
people do body
uh modification stuff
well i find that people do a body mod
like that i call body mud
body mod um i'm in the biz
i'm in the body my business um so
most of the most people that do intense
but are uh the one thing that they have
in common is they all have
bad personalities um
and he seems to have a you guys robert
you can write his own rhymes so if you
can write your own rhymes you're not a
boring person
no he's not boring yeah um i just think
he's more in the
he's just super weird just a weird guy
and maybe
a slight mental illness that would be my
guess
if i had to guess
he's a little something didn't he retire
also he does a lot of [ __ ]
yeah he's he likes attention
i yes i think i think um
so ah it just i mean if it gets snagged
it's like when people have i get my
forehead caught on things all the time
so he's in real trouble i mean it's good
if you want to
headbutt a window he's going to be the
first
the first through the door that's so bad
you're sending little losey vert they
hold them
like a battering ram that'd say he's
going to be used by lapd to
drug bust he's gonna they're gonna hold
him like a dwarf and do battering ramps
good he's he's gonna make his money back
on that diamond pretty quickly
with all the battering ram 26 million
dollars
is that i that's the other thing is i
want to go
how do you where'd you get that money
apparently
he's has more money than that he
addressed it because everyone's like why
the [ __ ] would you spend
that much money on a diamond he was
saying i have
so much more money than that that that's
nothing that's
not possible why is it not possible
because i know
i know people with hit songs
hits hits [ __ ] hints i know
people with hit careers they don't got
26 million
for a diamond because in order to have
26 million dollars for a diamond you
know much money you had to make
65 million dollars before taxes and
everything else
so in order to get it's so much money
i that's where i i go i think rappers
have a different
they're part of a different financial
stream or something where
like huh how'd you do that and then they
always end up 18 months being
uh bankrupt yeah you can't make 65
million dollars on the road like
he can't make that kind of money he just
can't
like uh the maroon 5
people can right like he could levine
could afford a 27 million whatever the
[ __ ] it is 25
i just wrote it up i just upgraded it it
just appreciated it okay
um and also the resale value on a
forehead diamond
not what you slightly use yeah not not
what you want when there's a little bit
of goop there's a little bit of goop on
the base
um you're not it's a bad
uzi he didn't spend 26 minutes maybe he
put a down payment on it you can't
there's people yeah he's got 20 no he
doesn't
no he doesn't that's not on loan or
lease it's
he didn't pay 26 million for it what
happened
i don't know but i promise you he
doesn't have 26 million dollars
so funny to give to anyone do you think
it's a stunt like jacob the jewel is
like
this it's something yeah it's a d it's a
yeah it's like
it's on it's not it's like it's like
when they give it to the actresses
yeah there's a little bit of just
following around like and the guy said
put it where i can see it
and so he's like all right cut to
[ __ ] his forehead
uh but between the battery ram money
that he's gonna he's gonna make his
money but it's a good investment
but um he's uh
he's a little iffy a little iffy
but i did like the song where he kept
saying now i do what i want
now i do what i want now i knew what i
want it was a pure
distillation of what being nine years
old is like now
bianca did you watch aoc's ig live
no so i didn't actually know you're
talking about it's pretty big story
um she did an ig live where she talked
about
the capitalist
capital terrorism okay and um
she was talking about how she thought
she was going to die
and she was hiding in katie porter's
office
there's a shot from it very very
attractive woman
katie porter's office now
right wing people including michael
rappaport for some reason
he's not right-wing i know but on this
he was okay uh
we're saying that she was lying that
like it hadn't started yet her timeline
didn't make sense
um i mean and
but it's like well what do you think she
was safe
right the [ __ ] do you think like she's
wrong was she she's also not on the
stand like it's
fine it should be uh exactly what
as she knows right but i'm saying that
i feel like we can allow some
discrepancies with like the exact time
when you're
afraid for your life um she was hiding
in katy porter's office
and so what was the lie people were
calling her
that she was in katie porter's office
and
they were they were in another part of
the capitol
uh and that was three tenths of a mile
away
technically through tunnels but again
she you can't think she was safe
even your biggest critic has to go yeah
she was
adam schiff was on franken's podcast and
he said
that during the the the terrorism that
republicans said to him they can't see
you
like you especially you gotta hide and
imagine him pelosi yes if he was a hot
woman
um and uh and if you think
that aoc isn't under fire because she's
a hot woman
she believes verbatim the [ __ ] that
bernie
believes yeah and nobody wants to kill
bernie
or pill whatever they want to do to her
right um
so there was funny how bernie gets so
little criticism from the
far right because people face in tone
as we learned from my influence book two
months ago
she's good looking she's good looking
and has a scratchy
whiny voice yeah and and it seems
entitled whereas bernie seems like well
yeah
they he earned it somehow yeah exactly
um but the so the fact that they
uh
it's somewhat some things are just not
worth calling out
where it's like but what's your argument
that she didn't her story doesn't
do so do you believe she's a congress
person
what are you doing first principles so
you agree she's a congresswoman
how safe do you think she was that day
well
now i would argue that her makeup
tutorials hurt that but
you know you know i'm against makeup
tutorials um i do
i'm the michael rappaport of her makeup
where i
write underneath it um that's just one
of those fights that just
isn't worth having to me um moving on
and marginally terry the marjorie taylor
green
did get kicked off of her committee
committees so
not by republicans by democrats but
but she can't really because she was
voted in she can't really be kicked out
of her uh she can't be kicked out of
office right they well she could be it
takes 67 votes
um she just can't play with us
she can't i mean they they they say like
she's a feckless and she i mean that was
i was watching msnbc and they were
saying in a good way like she can't
bring money back to her district
and it's like well you know what the
problem there is
that other people can that because
they're on the committee
yeah but they were they're fine with
that and they're excited that she
can't bring money like you know this is
not good for us that there's
if you're on a committee you can bring
more money back to your state
just just saying lawrence o'donnell um
you can tell us yes uh i
know but i he's probably my least
favorite you can tell
what the anchors think of themselves
by their theme song oh what is his
his is like very uh
it's like orchestral and sort of
literary
because he's a hollywood guy and
uh so it's he thinks it's like a
merchant ivory movie like he thinks he's
like a
he's like a smart hollywood person right
with taste and class and dignity brian
williams
is military music because he thinks
he's in the military as we learned and
i've always said this
brian williams is doing a tom hanks
impression
and has been from day one put them next
to each other
he's doing tom hanks that's so funny
unequivocally doing tom hanks and like
kind of funny and studious and uh we're
gonna get you on the other side and my
guests have agreed and i would just like
to say that my wife rita
it's th he's doing tom hanks and
all of his
brian williams masturbates to himself
doing intros
for his panel he loves his like
and he has a and a pulitzer prize winner
and he's here with us
he has agreed to do another segment he's
uh
he i don't i don't i watch i gotta say i
think
it works on me but i but i don't like it
uh rachel maddow what did you think of
herself her
theme music is um
you know
sixth grade detect harriet that's fine
like that's her what she thinks herself
like i'm a scrappy little
right spitfire and i get the job done
it's like it she doesn't even have music
it's just like
it's yeah
that's because she's always on the move
dude they don't have the music in cnn
uh i was like
done and then that's the breaking news
but i don't know what the beginning of
of don lemon is yeah or or um i feel
like it would be sexy
homeboy um look that's you can get away
with that joke
i look if i do that joke in february
this whole thing gets shut down um
the um
and then uh what's his name
uh chris hayes yeah his is
i the thing i'll say with chris hates is
his intros are so weird we'll go like
tonight like why are you yelling like
john mclaughlin
tonight it's totally like the mclaughlin
yeah it's so weird like dude don't
do just have don't do that i don't it
doesn't it doesn't matt you're not like
you don't
hello tonight paul manafort
just do the [ __ ] news weirdo um
now yeah so that's all i have to say
about that
uh that was a segment called msnbc a
audit of style moving on um
what's this oh the country music kid who
says
he climbed out of the theo von swamp
um he you keep saying the animal
stop walling morgan wallin
i can't like he said it uh can you um
the circumstance in which he said it was
like people were making noise
and he was dropping something and he's
like take your damn put it in here
it just was bad it was just like bad
sloppy but apparently his
his uh record sales are through the roof
you're kidding
you mean he's being rewarded for being
yeah
rocket sky rocket that was that that was
what
some country music fans were waiting for
like is this guy real enough
he said it all right let's go down
authentically
down
uh they rose 1200
last wednesday once he said the n-word
so that's the thing it's not but country
music not
racist it's just except in this one
case when a guy said the n-word and was
rewarded
uh now they opposited marjorie taylor
greendam
he got put on committees yes uh he got
put on
committees take care of this pussy-ass
[ __ ] and then he goes on to say
tear this [ __ ] ass n-word don't like it
i don't like it um
but what are you gonna what are you
gonna i mean no one's surprised
except for maybe white people i don't
think that well
yeah clearly they were they were on the
fence about them
and then once they heard him call the
n-word they call the wild they were like
i gotta get off the fence
i don't think why people are surprised
no i think
i think i i can't i whenever i hear
white people say the n word like in in a
situation like this i'm like
what the [ __ ] right and i and
everyone knows my history with it so
like
what the [ __ ] are you at least i had the
decency to say it
as a thing on stage like here you go
very decent of union tata
um but
couldn't have been nicer the way i did
it uh hearty gold
but yeah this just the funny thing is
it's
clearly a neighbor like a nosy neighbor
yeah with a cell phone mm-hmm um
now i'm on his side now i'm on morgan
maulin's you're like don't dox him
but the the thing is i mean
that's when no one was looking when he
was drunk uninhibited
and he didn't think anyone was looking
yeah it's just
weird it's a weird there weren't black
people around
it wasn't in response to a black person
he was calling a white person
his friend he was telling someone take
care yeah
of my boy so well it's just real
comfortable
it's just it's so it's just when you
think about it a country music
star says a [ __ ] freely
is bad writing yeah
but as we've learned this year
the world is bad writing a lot of
parasites oh
a lot of people said by the way somebody
tried to compare parasite to white tiger
because i like white tiger
yeah like it's never seen the thing
yes and guess what my problem with
parasite was
the workers were the parasite nobody
like this kid actually said like i'm a
dick
in white tiger yeah where he wasn't
looking for sympathy he was literally
like
i'm fighting fire with fire hello i'm
a capitalist and it literally says white
people
are yesterday and the future is is brown
and yellow
like great great great yellow love
it yeah yellow and then he said morgan
while and has my permission to say the
n-word
it's a weird movie where he said that he
called it
um now what is his face
a guy got a face transplant the first
well we
searched face transplant guy got
the first like full face transplant four
days ago
in jersey um was he
like a mentalist
well you know what's funny is he just
they made him they made him just look
like a blogger
like that's where my face mask thing
comes in the hand
my face might but i don't get it this is
the new one or the other face yes
and then why is his eyes dark like that
like does he have eyeballs
uh maybe not
they just made him look like he's got uh
he's uh
on ain't it cool news they just made him
look like
he's got he runs a a film website
he looks like a film buff yeah um oh
this is the
what's going on here those are his
parents oh yay
yeah it's not bad i just the dark eyes
it's a little scary sorry sweetheart
sorry i'm sorry they're
i guess they're still sorry we did
everything we could
that eyes are too dark take it off
um yeah yeah it's cool um
yeah i basically just had that on here
so i could say he looks like a blogger
i was i get went down
this is okay because i'm i'm a dick i
went down a rabbit hole of
these random stories of people getting
transplants
and then taking on personality traits of
the the donor what
how about how crazy um from what i
understand the story was really
the quotes of the it was a black kid
that died and
older white gentleman got his heart i
let's just go on a limb start making
beats no oddly enough the black kid was
um a violinist okay and they knew they
got his heart from a black kid and
the quotes are a little dodgy the quotes
are saying well we didn't think
uh so basically all of a sudden
her husband started listening to
classical music
never listened to classical music in his
life or cared about it and then just
started taking on certain traits
but the quotes were like we didn't think
it was
it was a black kid so why would he start
listening to
classic i love it especially this month
right i love that kind of racism and
then they said you know he
he started inviting he's never invited
his
black friends over his co-workers over
never really
had much to do with them outside of work
and then started
foraging friendship that's fine
there's an old movie that with denzel
and bob hoskins called heart condition
where there's it's a heart-switching
movie
and i don't remember who got what but
what's the premise
uh denzel gets i think bob hoskins gets
his heart
uh-huh or vice versa and i
didn't watch it but i know that that's
the premise i don't like
switching movies uh i bought this old
60s movie poster
because it was too racist and like this
needs to be in my hands
and where it's safe i have a pin that
says [ __ ] iran
because of during the i think the
petroleum shortage
i'm like i'm you'll be coming with me
called petroleum
sorry i like the pretty european special
yeah gas we call it the gas shower i
know okay
you know what it's actually patrol okay
so by the way
in the documentary uh lady in the dale
there's a there's footage of the gas
shortage in the 70s
interesting and a woman's just
complaining
they should have said they were out
again and they might as well just put
vaccine and just people can't [ __ ]
stop
complaining about anything they it's in
they're incapable
anyhow go ahead um so i
bought it and it's a poster
it's a movie in the 60s called change of
mind and
uh uh a guy needs a bla
brain a little guy needs a brain
transplant and the only available one is
from a black man and the whole movie is
about
the tagline is uh black man's brain
white man's body and the love making
seeing the wife scared
it's so bad well will you look up
heart condition or no you won't you
refuse
been waiting heart condition what is
that that's just heart condition
heart condition denzel washington okay
cardiac arrest heart disease
who did what this looks like twins uh
well every post in the 80s looked like
you fool uh once we had a hit
right it was like someone lean on the
other dude to rise
rivals compelling competing in the same
work
area in their community to help bring
down the drug rate
the goal will be to find a mysterious
man that shot and killed napoleon stone
uh denzel of course napoleon stone the
black guy gets shot you're not
questioning hello
um didn't do well made four million
dollars
but that's in the 80s okay hoskin
yeah but it's not i don't know if it's
nominally
bitcoin it's four million dollars is not
good
um uh hoskins plays
police sergeant jack mooney a racist
bigoted cop in
washington plays napoleon stone an
irresistible
persuader an ambulance chasing lawyer
who uh
mooney hates the feelings are mutual
stone goes
on to date mooney's ex-girlfriend
whoopsie daisy
uh who stirs up the pot between the two
moonies here's a bad habit such as
overeating smoking and drinking finally
catch up with him risking his
health and life at the same time stone
is gunned down in a drive-by shooting
which uh happened to 80 of black
characters
before 1995. after suffering a heart
attack mooney wakes up to find that his
new heart was
once stones and the dead lawyer's ghost
has become his constant companion
oh he's he he goes dead
yeah ghost dad and here
they they just flipped it by adding the
heart element
um is it a comedy i think it was
supposed to be they tried to make bob
hoskins like in uh
what's the the animated one the people
love
oh the uh who framed roger yeah robert i
mean that's it from roger
it's a cool movie but it's great bob
hoskins being it did not help it
he was he's kind of like that generic
like hey
but he's also british so he's like
british that's why i never bought it he
was like you know this clown's british
suckers get get dennis farina in there
oh my god
our rest in peace uh rust and power
cannons empowered
one of the greats you know dennis arena
when he died his heart went into
sebastian
i've always said sebastian is dennis
farina that's so the man i saw was like
oh it's dennis farina who can write
jokes
you're going to be a billionaire and
sure enough
he just put a diamond in his face
sebastian put a diamond in his face
it's a scene he's got the money do you
see the diamond
in your face um
[Music]
the face transplant oh okay the biggest
okay
guys we gotta talk kung fu vagina vagina
um did you see the [ __ ]
yeah i don't understand how
people still think th that they can get
away with this
i think you can play it because play it
on diet yeah i mean it's it's add
[Music]
like kung fu fighting is already racing
and no one talks
like you're not allowed in
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Music]
now here's the problem call it
but if you're doing it kung fu gina
call kung fu kitty it's same [ __ ]
kung fu kitty sounds like
it's already been out like that i think
it has that already sounds like
something what is kung fu kidding
set a new google combo kitty i feel like
it's something
kung fu kitty isn't it a restaurant
no it's a it's a cat the number one
thing is a is a
it's a video on youtube of a cat and
they just put added sounds
where a cat does
it's just youtube so just call it kung
fu kitty it's not
like that's a and then no the concrete
they're
selling uh a young like a jade eggs that
you like yoni eggs like uh
so you can do kegels kegel stuff
kegel adjacent stuff but apparently it's
a class
well they also say you know which raises
some coveted questions
are we doing classes now i think it's
virtual i mean you don't need if you're
not
doing mask on your [ __ ]
so they're saying that jade eggs
in your [ __ ] is ancient chinese secret
when it's not
there's actually no evidence that
chinese
people put jade eggs up their [ __ ] yeah
like somebody they would do it for
storage
if anything if i know anything about the
the chinese
they're there are brutal people who
would do some [ __ ] like that just
because like why or else i put it and
then that's their answer
um yeah i guess uh goop said
uh it was like the secret of concubines
to put the eggs up there and this is a
whole other issue
but and i
think i've said this before when beyonce
had the lyric about bomb ass [ __ ]
i said to my girlfriend at the time it's
all bombast [ __ ]
there's no no no we don't want it no
don't ruin
the fantasy yeah no vagina
yeah no vagina is better than another
one we need
some are a little looser yeah yeah
okay like occasionally for the most part
it's fine like
once in a blue moon you'll get like damn
whoa but not in any
not in any uh
noticeable market way neil don't ruin
our fantasy i know what's the pain i'm
trying
i'm letting you off the hook no we need
to first of all it's it's
it's a little intrusive a penis goes in
us and shoves all of our organs
up and down so i don't think it shoves
your organs up and down
others they're not like what they're not
like
what did you do with it it's not just
like i don't
doubt that yeah when you know what i'm
down i'm just saying that like
i think that's why we need to feel
something about them this is really way
more unique spend your time
watching video coming up a funny [ __ ] to
say okay
okay limited
so they i just they don't this was so no
one said
maybe this isn't a good idea i think
they're just
like chicks i don't think that they're
especially smart i don't think that
they're in marketing i don't think that
i don't think that they had any history
of good videos or
i mean this is a classic case of like
skits are not for everybody
no racist racial skits not this
you got a tender takes a [ __ ] tender
[ __ ] a tender hand that you can
[ __ ] up uh racial [ __ ] like this and i
think they're white people
oh yeah both white one looks asian in
the video because of her makeup because
of the great asian makeup she did um
that's pretty cool that she went the
extra mile donation makeup
what should they do uh just go away
just go away i mean they were never here
it's like
they don't have to do anything just go
back to whatever they were washing cars
or whatever they were doing for one okay
um there's i don't really have a
idea for this other than i there was a
list on reddit of white injuries
that really made me laugh uh these are
things
in at the er that
the percentage of people that suffered
from them were white
okay good they are skeet shooting 100
white ski i shouldn't say i'll say ski
treating injuries
and we'll assume it means participants
yeah
uh snowmobiles 98.3 all right now i will
say i bet black people would like
snowmobiles
they're so fun yes if they don't if they
[ __ ] with them they would like it the
same way
like black people in the south yeah i
mean yeah yeah
and and like little duvall would have
all kinds of
like well it's not i just they're fun
have you haven't you driven 18 i have a
beach
cd you know what i've done i did yes in
costa rica yeah and it but they
you got when you rent a thing like that
you gotta hope that
the kids are high and are irresponsible
why
because they'll let you do [ __ ] that
they wouldn't normally do
if they're just like the if the boss is
there it's a way worse time
but they'll take the most fun i've ever
had in my life
is jet skiing in puerto rico on waves
and uh with like a bunch of
19 year old puerto rican kids in charge
perfect
the best the most fun i've ever had in
my life and it was in
it was in 2003. i'll never forget it
it's been a while
it happens you've had i know what i've
learned i've done but
i've done jet ski since but
there's so many rules whereas this was
like i don't know so
you just like where five feet waves
wow jet ski oh my god was so
i you i was laughing as in midair
yes i i knew i was about to get crushed
and it was making me laugh
that's so funny and i was like it was
[ __ ] so fun
um and of course roller hockey not
surprised
they don't even play they even made it
to ice hockey let alone roller hockey
um tree stands what's that i guess
that's a hunting
like hiding in the in the nook
just like waiting for the the blind
yeah and they're in the blind thank you
um and they they i guess the blind
collapse
uh utility vehicles from the people who
brought you snowmobiles
utility vehicles 96 white injuries
tarpaulins which are just tarts i don't
know what did you eat them
what did you do hanging up tarps
people do that black people even
yeah power routers
95 that feels like a generator yeah that
feels
um uh
garden tractors okay yep um
it's a log splitter um
exactly what you think it is how does it
how does it work oh it's just like
yeah yeah which i gotta say
one of my worst fears is a
uh blade accident yeah did you take
woods i took woods
a lot of is that a class woods class
never heard of it in my life you acted
like we were both
it was everyone's been offered woods
wait
you've never taken woods no one's heard
of this
so there's woods and there's metal
readers are driving into oncoming
traffic
the listeners are driving into oncoming
you didn't take woods
like there's a moment like it's normal
i've never heard of it
i've never heard of it wood shopping we
all know how old i am
wood shop class wood shop yes that's a
thing
yeah woods i just i just oh you're
indeed you're like [ __ ] shorting it
super cool y'all and y'all taking one
i'm gonna smoke this j and hit woods
um did you take wood shop i didn't they
didn't i went to catholic high school so
they didn't play all that homework [ __ ]
we had like
woods and medals sorry wood shop and
metal shops i took shame classes
uh and everything even to this day
there's contraptions that scare me they
shouldn't have them in school i mean i
don't
i there's a saw there's just there's a
squirrel
this you have to there's a
type of uh like a sander so it looks
like that and on one side of it the
downside is where you
sand things and whatever and if you put
anything on the upside
it's like flies off yeah
gone into the ceiling scraped to the
bone
there's just so much that can maim you
yeah and and disfigure you and a lot of
different
drill bits and saws
yeah now the the flip side is i'm
i'm a i'm a wealthy old woman at this
point when it comes to
like you're doing shut down walker yes
um i'm i'm although i did
no i didn't i got some i
puts up some wallpaper that was cute and
do you feel do you
like when you do something does it does
it feel sad i like it
i talked about it on our podcast our
award-winning podcast um
i talk it's great and i want i almost
got a drill bit
and i actually did buy it and returned
it and i might have to go back and buy
another one
because i had another worker here and i
had him put it in
my uh stud i hung up some painting
at one of kevin christie's works above
my bed so why
am i doing i found i gotta stop today
you have a drill i don't i want to get
one oh interesting i had one and
returned it because i was like i don't
think i'm gonna need it and now i know
you always need a drill
yeah but they're what i couple things
they're
a hundred bucks which is kind of a lot
for
a thing i got a black and dagger one
that's 45 bucks
with like a bunch of bits cordless
cordless and it has the um
cordless and it has the like the magnet
it has a light
i'll send you a link i'd love to borrow
that okay
yeah i need i need uh i
i guess i'll buy one it's at home depot
yeah but they're all there all the ones
i saw were like 110.
weird okay i'll just send you the one i
i'll look at the one i got then or you
can just borrow it i use it once a year
but that's what i mean like and again i
make a decent living
i just it seems like a waste of [ __ ]
to buy i kind of want you to borrow i
love i
now my my home is full of dumb [ __ ] i
mean i bought a 200
shot collar from my wrist so but i
refuse by 100 do you wear it
you're running out of wrist real estate
kind of weird i'm waiting
the guy from pavlok contacted me oh why
because i mentioned it oh cool
and um but they have a new
addition coming out of the padlock where
i can attach it to my
this watch yeah so because in the way it
kind of looks
it's goofy um but uh it
helps come in you'll see um
so what else white archery of course
coal or wood-burning stoves
um that's appalachian this one got me
and i realized that it's actually
whiter than normal skiing which is water
skiing
which combines water skiing was number
94 in terms of injuries
think about you don't see a lot of black
people water skiing
or are they just better than white
people at it
oh you're saying that they're not
getting injured because of their natural
huge muscles that they have from slavery
yes and they're buoyant all of a sudden
black history month you're buoyant if
you're gonna swim this is the month
february the god made you buoyant this
month
do you believe the buoyant sea theory i
was told it
by a white person and it was no well i
know but that's what i'm wondering it's
like
what is the there's of course what white
people what black people tell white
people
and then there's what black people tell
other black people no this is about what
white people tell black people
no no but i'm saying there's things that
bible will deny up and down
and then on the side it'd be like
not a little something i don't know the
side part i believe you i just don't
yeah
no no this one i was at some dumb
hollywood party
the best example is chris's n words
first black people joke like a lot of
people say that forever but then they
were mad at chris for saying it
in front of white people yeah well i
don't know because
this guy was like oh yeah i have friends
from
compton and they can't swim they're too
dense black people
dense their bone density i was like and
he was complimenting how well i was
swimming
i just i learned a lot
swam away pretty great swam away
um uh uh
a small small world chris learned to
swim during covet
okay a lot of people are learning
sebastian did too yes sebastian
and john legend all took swim lessons in
the last couple years
it's so [ __ ] cute i and you know who
might be nice you don't know how to swim
i know how to swim i just not it's not
impressive
like if a girl wants to [ __ ] me i cannot
take her swimming
because seeing doggy paddle isn't gonna
oh my god
isn't gonna i was on swim team moisten
the loins
i can i swim in the ocean
that's where a lot of people swim what
does that mean you swim like you'll swim
i swim like at past the waves swim
like go for a swim and like how you keep
saying it like
like swim oh like a what do you do like
that's where you swim like i need to
swim laps
excuse me sir where's the pacific yeah
kind of like i like going all the way
down and back
as far as like just like really far up
and back
freestyle now the question is such a
good workout it is a good one
hard but is it [ __ ]
is it it's kind of the workout what it
does to the body is what i like
it doesn't least impact and it works
every muscle
but it doesn't do you get lats and all
the [ __ ] you want
i get it but there's no i'm trying to
there's no right but you think about
the olympic swimmers they got lads
they're all like shredded but it also
butterfly really
like it depends on your stroke i think
but but
um when you do swim it's the only thing
that
not the only thing but it you lose fat
and you tone up
right simultaneously yeah i like the
sounding you know i like the tone
yeah i would not but you know but it's
something i'm saying it takes a long
time
what does i think sebastian was saying
it's gonna like gonna take them a year
to learn
swimming yeah i i don't know maybe once
you're an adult
maybe it's hard it's just you have to
face fear a lot more than when you're a
kid
are you afraid of the ocean yeah
okay of course how do you not how are
you not afraid of the ocean
how is anyone not afraid of the ocean
nothing
i would argue there's nothing more
terrifying in the world than me the
bering sea is frightening
but i mean are you afraid of the pier
like just swimming out
that's a scuzz issue i don't mean in
between the fear i just mean are you are
you afraid of just venice you go out
like
it'll never happen i think even if i
take lessons
can't feel your can't feel the sand uh
unless there are waves like
body surfing there is no incentive for
me to swim
because it doesn't look good and i don't
get anywhere fast okay
so i don't it's not good as a mode of
transportation and i look weak
yeah really you need a swimming pool
just a gym membership and then
no i know i would i no i would but i
don't think i could even
learn i would need a lesson for sure
because i don't
i i could do what i see on yeah um
and i as much as i say like i don't i
can like if we race i've won races so
it's not
oh i just don't i don't know what i'm
doing
is the point is i have no idea what i'm
doing so
if people go like you curved i'm like
yeah of course i curved
i don't know how i don't know how to do
it yeah
but people do say it's a good workout
but then you can
he i yeah uh white injuries
um we did them all no we didn't
oz chisels or planes that goes back
log splitters if you don't if you don't
learn in woods then you're listening
if you don't know we don't know tractors
this goes with garden tractors tractors
92 percent injury
ice hockey 92 percent whites
and snow skiing 92 whites um
so stay safe black people
it's your month
[Music]
uh doc watch will document
great did you watch assassins
i did not watch yourself very good movie
good story
interesting uh
and
it's the story it's the story of the two
women who killed kim jong-uns
oh yeah brother in the airport oh yeah
that's
so wild yeah but i've deep dove into
that
okay maybe you don't have to watch it um
just the prank show it's just so
it's what she's saying is so they killed
i mean this was in the news but
they killed him and then said
like we thought we were on a prank show
and you hear that and you're like that's
insane
yeah you you go well that's insane
but is it like is that insane that's it
there are enough
[ __ ] prank shows yes there are enough
prank shows now
that you don't know
and people want to be famous like
there's plenty of reasons it could be
true
and then they go into it and
it's it's true yeah
um but it took them a while they were
held and then
the government had to go and don't but
don't say any more
because it's they go into the whole
trial okay yeah
um it's i forget why he wanted
his uncle because he was talking greasy
straight up it's not his uncle's brother
i thought it was his
his no are you sure it was kim jong-il's
son
his other son so they had different moms
oh but they
there was at one point the brother was
going to be was going to be the
president and then i went to
and then he started playing some mbs
[ __ ]
where he he was currying favor with kim
jong-un
or kim jong-il and then kim jong-il
died kim jong
un got the job and then
killed the brother anyway because he's
[ __ ] psycho yes um
and uh but it's it's
the you know my takeaway was women in
asia are [ __ ]
that was my big because the thing that
led them to
doing it in the first place like their
lives sucked so bad before
right one of them was it had been a pro
it's just like [ __ ]
it's just like
even i was like disgusted there's
disgusted
there's a really stupid show that i used
to watch called scare tactics i think
yes
yeah steven baldwin was the house it was
very bad sure
and um they were just trying to scare
people and one of
the pranks they would pull is they
pretended the person was on a fake prank
show
and then they would do something that
would accidentally kill someone
right and then they were you know the
person in a show
in a show within a show like no well
what the [ __ ] and that's all
i'm like it's so like why would someone
think they would that would actually
kill someone
you know what i mean like it's so wild
that it could just
work yeah they you know what i don't
want to get into the
specific of the documentary but uh
the thing once i heard it i was like oh
it wasn't their first prank
oh with these guys so once i heard that
i was like oh
damn that's deep they just do some like
they fake they i mean you want to talk
about yeah so
that it was just interesting [ __ ] it was
interesting
in that how innocent they were right and
and
yet there was no stopping the trial
even though it was like yeah but it
didn't matter apparently
i i won't i hope does not get anything
away but the
what they use the poison like they
didn't really take care that it wouldn't
have
also poisoned the girls they didn't tell
them
don't touch your face yeah um they knew
it was like
bad but they didn't know it was vx
the most poisonous substance on earth
that you
cannot get any no one ha like
governments have it yeah yeah um
for a rainy day the government's hold on
to it just in case they need it
uh frontline did a china
china virus
and it's the same
it was all it wasn't boring but it's the
story of corruption government
corruption is always the same
yeah which is lying and then slowly but
really being like
okay you might they said you can't
there's no person to person transfer
for a month they said that and they're
like there might be
and then yeah and it's like but then
there's another guy
who was on mar who thinks it was just
straight up created in a lab
i know me and my brother are talking
about that and because i mean you've
been
i don't care i don't think that they
released it intentionally right
like that's the problem in a lab it's
stupid but and it is like
that with some what are you gonna do
[ __ ] but but we were talking about it
and i've been to those wet markets and
um lovely they're so gross so
basically the what is the mucus membrane
around our type of covid
is either from a bat or some sort of
reptile or lizard so
they were saying that uh
that because the way they keep them in
wet markets okay well maybe it did come
from what we were just debating it
because he works for cbs news and he was
just telling me how
there's other examples of weird ass
coveted strains popping up in places
where
i think he was telling me in denmark
i don't know the minks yeah where they
keep the minks really close together and
then to kill
all the minks because they were
developing like a form of code so he
was like it could have been in a lab
because
the thing that the guy said weinstein
said on
mars show is that the reasoning things
to make
happen in a lab is because of the way
it's mutating it's like a type of
mutation
that doesn't really happen in natural
pathogens
weird but i i it's above my pay grade
like i'm a know-it-all and i'm like you
know what neil sit this one out
um brittany
you know didn't hulu
new york times yeah didn't love the doc
it was not remarkable it was interesting
half of it one first half i feel like
yeah the first half was just an mtv
thing
yeah it was just uh the real hollywood
story
yeah but the second half i just didn't
know
it's [ __ ] weird i feel like either
they know something
that we don't know about her mental
health
that they don't want to get out like why
wouldn't the thing that
that i was telling will this before he
you got here
was the reason
all of those goofball fans
think that there's some like britney
doesn't do those kinds of emojis
the reason they've never they can't
believe that
she could be sick is because they've
never seen
us anyone actually sick and doesn't know
how they react
doesn't know how people with mental
illness behave
which is some of them are really good at
covering it up
and so they can so they say stuff like
i'm sad
i wanna i don't want the conservatorship
and you go oh she said
and then you don't know what she's like
when the camera's not rolling
like she there's a very good chance
she's legitimately mentally ill
there is but when you watch it you
realize okay
got that point but she's not saying for
it to go away she's saying i don't want
my dad oh yeah they should
switch the person that i have no problem
with and because
a lot of the time from what i understand
you really have to be
like out of your mind you know to have
this and for them not to lift it
when you're you retain a lawyer you're
petitioning for
it to get removed it just feels like
there is some
it's a hard thing to undo it's a hard
thing to undo but you're
but we trust you to headline a
like two-year um you know residency in
vegas
yeah to me i mean what's more
nerve-wracking figuring out like
being it having more control over your
life or
standing up in front of millions of
people night after night
and not [ __ ] on stage so it's my life
is where everything falls apart
i'm a i'm i'm a i'm a rookie at life
that's the thing it's like professional
on that stage yo if she was suffering
that bad
her shows would be terrible they would
be kanye west
yeah but but none of her it's her shows
are
connie did some good ass shows he did
whilst
mentally ill and he did some very odd
behavior
yeah he left he left one because if your
wife got robbed at gunpoint in paris
he'd leave him well that one but there's
some that
i'm just saying there is kanye is
relevant
in this discussion here's why i think
he's relevant because
do you remember when i i posted a thing
from sunday service
yes and i said uh uh
like kanye is a great guy when he's not
mentally ill
but you can't say he's mentally ill you
said
all right yeah um and um
you can't say that he's not mentally ill
then he released an album called
uh i hate being bipolar it's awesome
so can i say he's mentally ill yet it's
these fans get it in their head that
like you can't talk about this person
that they don't know they only know
through their albums
and i happen to know a little bit
personally so i can say
i think it's it's like the story i told
you growing up when
my best friend at the time her sister
had mental handicaps
i think she was some sort of maybe
downton i don't know
and i would say mentally [ __ ]
i don't know that's what i said they
said we say special mm-hmm
so then i said special yep but sometimes
people don't like the
the the raw the unrefined
sugar they want they don't like your
right but connie's mentally ill
i think to people it sounds mean oh i
don't i mean what should i call them
unwell ah that's too vague
sick no that sounds like he's coughing
up just mentally i'm fine with it but i
think fans are very
fine cool doesn't change the outcome at
all
one bit 100 uh and
this is a side note but during the
during the
one of the commercials the
heart-wrenching commercials
about the special about the girl without
the legs yeah
she's an olympic athlete um
i have the thought that uh coaches for
the special olympics spend most of their
days
yelling at handicapped people
which has got to be pretty satisfying um
because when else can you yell at
handicap people
um you want to am i right fans
did you watch the lady in the dale i
didn't you didn't watch it
it looks good and it's great and it's
four parts which
oh i love it thank you thank you thank
you for the material
thank you for occupying occupying my
time
uh it is great and i won't
say anything else about it it's it's
crazy
back when you could really when you
could really get away with it
like fraud
like it was the the ladies selling a
three-wheel car
okay don't tell me anything basically
she's selling that motorcycle that rock
got me that i
sent back um she's selling a three-wheel
car
so why would you send it back didn't
want it
were we doing the podcast then i don't
know i just remember he got it for you
yeah chris rock got me a three wheel
motorcycle for helping on tambourine
and uh the guy delivered it to my house
and i he told me what it was and i go uh
i don't wanna
and he was like what are you talking
about i go i don't want the motorcycle
and he's like well it's paid for it i
was like i'm not taking it
because i knew once it got in my garage
it was never leaving
no and he's showing me like what it is
so what when you when you were firm what
did he say
well yeah i find he he there was a a
button on the thing that was anti-skid
and i was like
i gotta push a button not to skid i
would hope that would come
standard he's just roasting the guy
dropping you know
it was just like the [ __ ] you have to
wear a helmet
in it all the time um
so it's like it was like two side cars
oh god no with three wheels uh
and i finally said i i'm not
taking it like what should i and he goes
all right i can
tell you what i can bring it back to the
dealership and we can sell it on
consignment
and and i thought i'm going to make 27
grand
and then it turned and then like a month
later i called the dealership and i'm
like hey where them
where's my money right and uh they're
like oh you didn't they were like well
you know that thing where they keep
putting on hold and you're like that's
something i'm getting [ __ ] somehow
and the guy's like oh you didn't hear
they gave it to somebody else
so rock just was like oh neil don't want
i'll just give it somebody else that's
really funny that you
still called to be like hey where's my
mind um
i want to get a drill bit sir but i
don't got the money
um let's do some emails everybody
[Music]
rst nle question how important is it to
be pursuing your passion
versus working and spending a lot of
your life waking life just paying the
bills
so i've heard neil go on and on about
his creative endeavors blah blah which i
assume qualifies neil's achieving his
dreams with the financial comfort that
brings
i'm just curious to love being around
comedy but wouldn't consider herself a
community and i hope that's right
i'd say you're a new media superstar in
the making but not sure if that's
important to you or not
or qualifies as chasing your dream so my
question how important is chasing your
dream versus doing something to pay the
bills
do you both think you're doing what you
love every day and if not how important
is that to even do
yeah what nardothardo and bianca
love you
[Music]
well here's here what i've learned about
dreams
a lot of my dreams as i don't know if
you heard it but when the guy said
pursue my dreams and i said like i'm
just getting started there's nothing
worse than a person who's like
i'm just getting started with i'm just
scratching the
surface with my dreams shush it um
a lot of times if you if you think about
it your dreams
a lot of the dreams that i pursue are
the dreams of a 15 year old boy
and i'm just still pursuing them right
uh
[Music]
a part of me thinks that at a certain
point you have dreams and then you
you are pursuing them because
you just don't want to lose like well i
started it's like a bad money it's the
sunk cost fallacy thing uh
so i would suggest the best way to
pursue dreams is think about what your
why and why it's like and then what just
go and then what
and what you're probably looking for is
some some level of fulfillment or
acceptance or appreciation from other
people
if you can do that yourself you can save
yourself a lot of time
you can save yourself like a decade of
a thing that you might even succeed at
but there's just
it just gets to the point where you go
like what do i
for instance i look at uh trayvon who is
on my
group text and he's got a he wrote a
short that's like trying to get an
academy award nomination for short for
whatever and he's got a movie that
idris elba is supposed to do and i the
way he talks about him like i remember
this feeling
of like i'm gonna yeah it's this thing
of like looking over the wall like i'm
getting over the wall
and and what he doesn't know is most of
the people on the other side of the wall
are the
biggest [ __ ] sluggers you've ever met
and you don't want i just
at this point my life don't want to
spend another second with any of them
right
so therefore i go okay i don't care
about movies i don't think they're
better than tv
i don't i don't want to do that it's
just not a thing i aspire to
but it a lot of that comes from
um having seen
what the bit played things out to their
completion
and realizing like oh okay
that not like that was foolish to do but
you just kind of see the
the limitations of kind of everything
yeah
um so that's what i would suggest to
somebody is like
think about what your um
why you're why that's your goal and then
from there work backward into like well
do i so
can i just get there on my own right
could i just give myself
the sum the pat on the back instead of
like
i and today i finally feel
but having said that the acceptance of
three mics felt [ __ ]
awesome right so i don't [ __ ] know
that but i would say that go
stand up goal is the goal in and of
itself in that i like stand up every
night i'm not doing it
too that my special's going to come out
right and like my buddy derek's in and
of itself
thing on hulu came out and i can see him
reckoning
with being occupied by this thing for
three years and then it's
out and it's not bad it's great it's
like very well received etc etc
but there is a
like the thud like that and being john
malkovich where they drop him on the
side of the highway right
back it's a thought
um what do you what are you what are
your what's your arc
with all this stuff i think i don't know
i think you need to get
i just think everyone has a spectrum
of [ __ ] that's in their wheelhouse and
there's
one end where you'd kill it and it
wouldn't take much effort at all
and there's one end that would be the
the the hardest thing that you could
you could possibly achieve with your
skill set and your personality type and
yada yada and so i think really it
depends on
a lot of factors or where you where you
put the marker on the spectrum
and i feel like you know this kind of
like
artists sort of creatives are always at
the hardest
end because it's just such a crap shoot
yeah
but it's
weird because you have to have some cues
that
somebody else besides you and people who
love you think
you're good at what you're doing so if
you just
cannot find some level of success
or let's just take stand up if you i
know people who
i get a feeling not like anybody anybody
would know but
open micros or people have just been
hanging around the store forever or
something like that
where it's like are you gonna make it or
are you gonna pop i don't know that's
the thing
where it becomes this thing of like i'm
not gonna give them the satisfaction of
seeing me it's like
no one's gonna notice look at the walls
of
the uh look at the hallway in the in the
in the
at the store or look at when you're
going up to the the or
for a show and look at everybody who's
lined
who lines the walls with your headshots
you don't know most of them yeah you
know one out of five
and at some point every all of them have
the same
you know and by the way the people on
the wall are a lot of them are people
that made it
just because that's how they put the
pictures up a lot of them in the hallway
aren't
maybe on the steps they are i think it's
the opposite
really because i've googled some of them
i'm like
but what i'm saying is it's the ratio if
you went
if you look at the average rundown from
the store sometimes it's david letterman
and gallagher
and other times it's 10 people you've
never heard of but that actually did
something i mean there is not everybody
is a letterman and
you know recognizable name even though
they did have momentum and they were
involved and
stuff like that i just mean at what
point
do you reason with
like where's your line in the center
yeah you're chasing a 15 year old girl
so
what if you haven't
done xyz by year 15
or something you know like it i don't
know but then you hear like uh
the marin story those are the ones that
these stories like i was walking like
angus that movie we
discovered in a mall yeah you know those
ones kind of
keep people dreaming yeah and keep them
well you know that's why i don't like
the oscars
because it because it promotes people
without talent to move to l.a
anything is possible i know the the if
you're a speaker
11 out of 10 on the looks department any
and a woman
you're right anything is possible for
everybody else
is stay stay where you are i said it's
the best
advertisement for extras in the history
of the world
it's good it's the oscars it's so hard
great ad
for come out work background everything
is
like beat the odds type of
oh yeah what they don't tell you is like
no they were they were doing pretty good
that was doing pretty good it's like a
lot of them have been acting forever
and yeah who knows what distribution
company owns that movie to get the
come on come on what are you talking
about all right listen i went to the
oscars and
i did not watch a lot of the [ __ ]
did not watch a lot of the award show
it's so fun
at the bar it's this one that's the real
show yeah well it's because the show so
far i went to the last oscars actually
and guess who i saw casa pierce goodbye
did they say neil's right
you've got me hello neonardo and binks
rsnle
i've gone back and decided listened
i've gone back and decided to re-listen
to all the episodes from the start
because i'm a maniac
and just can't get enough i'm currently
on get at how you live and i burst out
laughing this week and when you guys
were talking about how coronavirus is no
big deal
and just hysteria i'm sure you would
laugh as well
we all felt that way at the time anyway
i just wanted to comment on how
different i think neil is after the
ayahuasca
last week someone said neil would lose
his edge and i wholeheartedly disagree
i bounce back between all the old
episodes and the new ones and neil
is a changed person for sure but still
super funny and witty
[Music]
i just think he seems way less petty and
stupid [ __ ] rolls off him
way more anyway not a question but a
useless observation be nice to will
but don't actually be nice because when
you [ __ ] on them it's so damn funny will
you piece of [ __ ]
love you both no there's no question i
just wanted
people to hear that i'm a better person
of course you did um
not so much better that i don't need
compliments on the air
goodbye i'm not that much better don't
get it twisted
you've got me hey dear neil brennan is
this a form letter
um dear neil brennan i'm letting you
know as a black woman who prefers white
men
my boyfriend who i adore love of my life
echoes what bianca says
these white men really feel like they
own these buildings
uh i think she's talking about
government buildings because in truth
white men do own mostly my boyfriend put
eight years into the armed forces and
was
discharged just she's yeah uh honorably
but
he would never do the violence but say
he sympathizes because veterans have
been thrown away by both parties uh
democrats and republicans the middle
class feels abandoned and
disenfranchised great show keep up the
good work i'm 50 my love is 60.
just wanted to give you a window what
people are feeling love your humor neil
debbie um
i don't i cannot speak to the military
all i know
is that i know the va is very poorly run
yeah
no if i were in the military i would
just say stop it with the hero [ __ ] just
get us medicine
where does all the money go it's the
most well funded money
poorly actually in the bombs into
raytheon and all that [ __ ]
then give it to i was like
yeah i mean i've been to wrestling
people
yeah making people um the bomb where
they keep the bombs it's pretty it's
adorable
they keep in like ornate right it's like
japanese yeah um
and uh and yeah that
they shouldn't rely on jon stewart to
get them
funding and you know i mean like just
[ __ ] where you're where it's so
crazy uh
and yet they all claim to we love our
troops like
you sure fort life fort life doesn't
sound
good like the camps no well yeah it's
not i mean the
yeah what it's a mixed bag you're you're
getting
you get a pension you get a lot of [ __ ]
yeah fairly quickly
but you're
counting on a corporation
you're counting on not a corporation
counting on unknown
[Music]
uh entity that's not good
was not good to your forefathers in the
military
so know that going in do your research
do your own research it's q q said
q is military um uh
so yeah but i'm glad that they i
i mean that the amount of military guys
that are being found out
it's like 20 or something that we're
military ex-military or
law enforcement yeah goodbye um you've
got mail
hello neil and jar jar binks as an
excellent moral compass how do you
two feel about white people wearing
kangal hats in 2021
do you know what it means if a white
man's wearing a kangal in 2021
it means he is bald
full stop i'm positive if a white man's
wearing a candle
they're always bald i kind of feel like
he
like that guy's bald i promise you that
guy's bald
ll was always ashamed of the shape of
his head apparently that's why he wore
one
kevin spacey's bald uh does
travolta wear him um
i don't know if tarantino's bald he says
it no trouble sam jackson bald
um white people um
i was thinking a younger crowd queen
tarantino
oh this is hilarious that's billy
crystal bald
yeah they're all i mean a young joy
mcintyre
in a kangal baseball hat these are
terrible yeah these are not
bruce willis loves some item some items
of clothing need to be racist
just this you don't want this or whites
blacks only
blacks only yeah i don't disagree do rag
kangaroos
i don't think white people are rocking
directs very much anymore not like they
were in like
three years you haven't been to the
south lately yeah good point goodbye
you've got me hey n b i'm a 30 year old
eritrean raised in the u.s my girlfriend
is white from southern indiana has a
good heart after the capital riots my
girlfriend didn't like
that i called the domestic terrorists
crack or ass crackers
or vanilla isis by the way yesterday was
chris's birthday
yeah we o chris
will crisp rock cracker ass crackers
he gave us cracker ass crackers he gave
us
um the friend zone yeah which people
don't realize
he said his daughters don't realize it
that he's like you know i
did that i invented their friends um
what else is he giving us uh uh tiger
tiger woods
i mean he's got a lot of husbands [ __ ]
versus i mean yes
hello yes
um and he's great
um and no sexist champagne room and
so much so much um
still figuring out how to wear a mask
leave him alone this is his birthday
night his birthday but he's still
so for his birthday i gave my math class
um her main pushback uh
was her saying saying that it was it was
saying cracker ass crackers is as bad as
the n-word a lot of people in her family
she grew up with around our hardcore
right winger she voted for bite in 2020
yes sir but social injustice issues
still make her uncomfortable
i plan to marry her and i've told her
that uh
you just won't understand what
minorities deal with until we have kids
uh when speaking about racial issues uh
what do you guys suggest to help her
understand
that the people she loves aren't as good
as she thinks they are
i mean i don't know how do you tell
someone that i don't think you can
you can't tell them like i think you
just have to wait for your
father-in-law to call your son the
n-word and then she'll realize like wait
a minute
this is way worse than cracker-ass
crackers uh
yeah the cracker versus like n-word
thing
is so weird to me yeah it's just not
it's a false equivalent uh
also i think people think it's
because white people look like saltines
or something but it's really just
like cracking of the whip right and it
was
and redneck is because they would get
rednecks and they'd be in the field with
the slides
so it's like i don't know if she gets it
none of it hurts
white people it's all just describing
things well so was the mrm um i mean
uh it's it
their historic words and the history of
white people versus black people
is there's just you just can't we can't
be injured
yeah you can't injure us with a you
[ __ ] can't cracker ass cracker is
like
i just think he's not talking about me
whenever i'm a cracker i just think
it's not me and they also now dated yeah
peckerwood is that a package yeah it's
just like guys and like
trucks with their sleeves rolled up like
what and trying to run
uh blind people into sodos off the road
um so what are we just you're just gonna
have to wait you
look at what you're asking how do you
tell them how do you tell your wife that
her family's
shitty ah you're not gonna be able to
you have to understand if you really
wanna marry her those are your family
too
these people that he
doesn't think are good are going to be
related to your kids
so think about it
um i say end it tonight
that's a poisoner um the
hardcore she voted for biden i mean
she'll come
what you're asking her to do what you're
asking like white people like this to do
is it's what i
said when george flight is you're asking
white people hey clean out the garage
so she's like ah yeah ah
[ __ ] i don't want to clean the [ __ ]
garage
and she one day she might
but your sons are gonna have to help her
goodbye you've got me hey nalen bianca
lstner i'm a 26 year old white man
i recently was uh with friends and an
asian woman my age
who i just met accidentally opened my
phone
saying she mistook it for hers when
opening
it she saw i had used a black flex emoji
and a black queen emoji with my
girlfriend uh she called me out for bad
behavior and i explained to
her my girlfriend is black i'm aware of
digital blackface
and i only use it in our consenting
relationship my girlfriend has said she
doesn't care
and will send me white emojis when i uh
work out etc um the asian woman still
said i need to stop even though she
wouldn't have known if she didn't go
into my phone without permission
uh i see this as telling both me and my
girlfriend how to behave in our personal
lives uh now i have stopped other
problematic
things i've done with consenting black
friends using certain words around them
oh hello
a certain word around them in the past
because of the potential society on
professional repercussions even though
they told me
they didn't care also eventually i just
felt mad corny doing it
so my questions are i don't think you
should use the term mad corny
um i think it's cultural uh so my
questions are one is
behavior society sees as problematic
still bad to do even if your friend's
significant other consents to it
i believe friendship allows good faith
transgressions and
two if you don't see a moral problem
with consenting transgressions
is still is it still best to stop the
behavior to keep my straight white ass
out of trouble
it's a very good question um
i would bet you and i differ on this
i don't think so because we talked about
it already not the black
yeah you can send a black fist to a
black person
no i guess we do differ on this what the
hell are you talking about
if your girlfriend is black and you said
you went to the gym no i what i'm saying
is like we
go finish without sorry you can send a
black emoji to your black girlfriend
because you're representing you worked
out
your black muscles that's what it's
doing
if you're if you're a black queen i'm
not gonna send you
a white queen because then it lacks
representation
that's there's no representation if it's
i'm all for representation in emoji
okay uh emoji presentation
now the transgression within
relationships
i have an n-word defense that you're not
gonna buy
but here is what i would here's a
possible edward defense reading this
okay even though he's not asking for
that go ahead no
but he brought it up extra credit
if a black person is calling a white
person the n word
in a friendship the assumption is
this is no longer about race it's about
belonging you know what i mean clearly
it doesn't mean you
black person it just means you person i
[ __ ] with
so therefore i understand how a white
person and i've
never followed this for myself this from
my you know what i'm saying
a white i understand why a white person
then starts saying it because it becomes
not about race
it becomes about uh belonging yeah i
understand the psychology of it or
there's
words you just said psychology worldwide
okay
there's just words you use amongst your
friends that as soon as you
um i had a friend who was indian and she
would
do an indian accent with me all the time
we would do it
all the time together and i started
doing it
when she was not around and i that it
just
felt like ah yeah what am i doing
why am i doing this of course i agree
with that so
i'm just saying i understand how things
can get away from you if they're playful
and they're
light-hearted about race um
to where you get a little too familiar
outside of the like comment yeah i
understand that
but what the question becomes about
is there such a thing as too familiar
within the group
if it's it's a bit like
uh bdsm where it's like no we're
i've signed up for that yeah i signed
like and if
i don't want him or her to say the n
word i'll tell him
i think it's well it's different okay so
for the the
girlfriend boyfriend thing we've already
said you know of course you can be
racist
with your girlfriend what better place
hello you can just be inappropriate
on all levels and as long as
transgression is i can be very bonding
experience
right and as long as the person's
catching what you're throwing and can
throw it right back
and there's an understanding i don't
it's none of our business yes
but i don't know i dated a british guy
once and he
kept saying that's ghetto i was like
dude
yeah but i don't i don't like when you
say yeah i don't know why you're
yeah even though between us
whatever right it's not like i thought
he was i also when a white person says
ghetto they
they're never right where it's like well
what
what do you mean and they they'll
explain it and you're like
i gave him i gave him other words to use
like that i don't know
where babe's not seen as bad here but
ghetto you're i i don't know but
at the same time that was a boundary i
wasn't cool with and then he was like
okay i'm so sorry my bad so
if let's see i was cool with it is it
anybody else's business
i don't know i remember even charles
barkley talking about
dan marley a white basketball player
that he was that he's
cool with that he's still friends with
it was they played together
saying like dan marley you should stand
on the golf course
but he was saying it like we're cool
right it's like i know
dan's like
and then he they all got in trouble it
was one of these things where it was
like
oh no wait not we can't none of us can
do yeah but then
okay but the problem is let's say i
would i didn't mind if he said ghetto
right now i'm not really checking a bad
behavior
do you got to worry about when you leave
the
ranch as it were and he says ghetto
around a bunch of people that
haven't authorized him so that's the
problem so do we just
you know let's not even let's not get
into a bad habit
you know i'm all about setting habits
beyond
bianca was messing with her papers
and she got her desk in order yeah i
think uh it's a case-by-case basis but i
think
the asian woman i think do you know
about face id
it makes it so asian women can't open
your phone
also i accidentally met a woman that
berated me about my phone she
went into that's like not first of all i
don't want to
sh that woman is susceptible to stress
i'm not saying she's acting white but
she is susceptible to stress
um and she's got she's on her way to
make a yoni egg
goodbye hello my little neely whaley and
my
big dog beyonce hi i'm an every episode
active listener active listeners taking
off
i'd like to ask how the capital [ __ ] do
i stop offending my girlfriend
i've come to the conclusion that she's
really sensitive and or insecure
this doesn't overshadow how important
she is to me and how much she brings to
my life we want the same things out of
significant others we
we're loyal honest passion and absolute
best friends however
i offend her constantly and this is
important
but really trivial trivial things
i was surprised she didn't know who neil
young was or when
apartment searching i dislike a place
she liked
oh god uh she she she
let me read that again i was surprised
she didn't know who neil young was
or when apartment searching i dislike a
place she liked
she gets completely deflated and thinks
that i think she's dumb and takes my
differing opinions personal attacks
can't figure this out simply not
speaking isn't an option
uh what the [ __ ] do i do i love you guys
and never miss an episode let me know if
you can
need more personal inflation to include
this episode uh
as a lady what do you say nightmare what
a nightmare
yeah cons like no who the [ __ ] wants to
offend someone
when you're trying to have a good time
uh that's like that's like playing with
the ball
and then it ends up on the roof you
can't believe the ball it's
yeah but it's it's worse than that it's
like playing
tag and anytime you tag the person they
cry yeah and say
that you offended them and nightmare the
point of being a relationship half of it
is just to be
on the same page and laugh at least
that's the goal
in my opinion and she's so of
why she's so brittle also what hap was
there not signs she was this sensitive
sensitive people don't come out of
nowhere i think there are things that
you put up with
in the beginning and don't think you
just think they're going to go away
they're never going away
they're never going away they're babies
kids
shut up they don't die they multiply
you're not
gonna this is the guy this is the thing
i've come to okay
women are just
wildly sensitive i i've started thinking
that women
are weightless and men are gravity so
you just constantly like
oh no what do you mean of course you
know of course you're never
you guys i never i really do agree with
you you believe in horoscopes you
believe in like
[ __ ] goofy airborne [ __ ] like i just
think that
a man and a woman i think long distance
relationships
just goofy [ __ ] relative to men i just
think
you are excluding men from thinking
about all this [ __ ]
i think horoscopes 80 20 women demand
that's fine but the horoscopes are
i would suggest that you're like more
likely to find a woman who's sensitive
than a man who senses it
really i i i personally would argue that
yes that is so
i just i fundamentally disagree yeah um
so you're just dealing with a woman
automatically is going to be more
sensitive and the expectations
my expectations of my male friends are
nothing
and and their expectations of me are
nothing when i'm in a relationship with
a woman
the expectations are roughly 40 times
what they are with my next closest
relationship
did just but i mean i sometimes and
you've done this before where you try to
you kind of project how it is in your
sexual dating relationship and you
compare well with men they're like this
but you're not
[ __ ] or dating trayvon you know of
course not and that's the difference
yeah but i'm saying you don't have a
good you don't have good intel
on how sensitive
men are you know what i mean because
sometimes the date absolutely
so but what i mean you say it with such
certainty
my expectations i'm putting my
expectations
of a woman i'm dating sleeping with
and versus their expectations of me yeah
and
the there's a huge disparity big
disparity no i understand that
that's the and i don't know where i am
maybe i'm low
maybe i'm high but that's the thing that
guys
the adjustment for men is that you're
even just walking to the store it's like
i got it with a woman i gotta like
if there's a thing if there's bushes i
gotta say
and like women can read into everything
whereas men just don't read into much
women re
everything is a referendum on how he
feels about you it's that joke i used to
do about like you're not ready to be a
father
yeah yeah yeah yeah paul in the journal
well how the [ __ ] did this happen
that's the difference between men and
women in my
in my experience and as a guy you have
to know that going in
so i guess the reason why i don't see it
like that is because i think
both sexes i don't think it's a sex
thing
which i think you do more so because of
gender you mean
sorry yeah gender thing i think it's a
if that person's expectations are more
a traditional male female role and you
don't fulfill that like
you were doing an act out that i don't
know the listeners can't see but it was
very like
let me hold this open and oh my damn and
yes
all that [ __ ] i had a girlfriend get mad
at me for
not i i the list of things that girls
didn't say
i didn't i got her into my show
but the venue didn't know to save her
seats
it was standing room yes i would be mad
too i'm not gonna lie i wouldn't be mad
at you
i don't know what the guy is in the
world who'd be mad at that i would go
i don't like sandy i well or you could
go this is so [ __ ]
cool that he has so many
ticket sales that there are no seats
left you are moving your neck
because i can't history like i'm leaving
no no i just what
guy would ever leave his girl's show
because he didn't have a ch
like that's what i'm saying like just
this level of
behavior that you go no i need that's
ground for leaving and all of a sudden
you do the same [ __ ] you literally came
to my birthday in the moment they ask
you who you're with you're like i'm
leaving
because i don't want to go to clubs i
understand it wasn't it was just a bar
i'm just saying that like
that was that was the level you were my
girlfriend i would have gone like cool
i'm waiting when you got like ah i'm
goodbye right because i wasn't gonna
wait out of [ __ ]
no i understand i'm just like that was
my comment was on that level it wasn't
like
but what i'm saying is i would leave if
my friend had a party at a club and i
wasn't we weren't right that's what i'm
saying i was just sitting on that level
but your first response was i'm leaving
the show if my boyfriend didn't get me
no no i'm saying that you're my friend
so that's why i my response was like
you know what i think it's a [ __ ]
scenario anyways my point is that
with men and women if your expectations
are
more traditional then
because the same thing goes with me i'm
a lot less traditional of a girl right
especially to date
and i have the exact same thing they
think trying to wear the pants
trying to challenge them not i've had
guys not like
want me to dress sexy and have like an
outward personality and i remember i
went on
like a date with a bunch of his friends
and their girlfriends
and they were dressed one of them was
dressed pretty provocatively i was like
you would
you would be so mad if i were yeah and
he's like yeah but he's
she's just by his side not saying
anything
so uh i do think there is this huge
sensitivity with men that we don't
really address or they don't have this
like
stereotype that goes along with it
because women are traditionally more
emotional but when a guy feels
challenged
the emotions come out when a guy feels
like
any in the same vein that a woman feels
oh he doesn't appreciate yeah
when when that version with a guy
happens it's the same level of emotion
that's the only reason why i was like
well i think i said this last week as a
liberal man i have no rights
what do you mean because i can't do
anything that would be
slightly interpreted as anti-feminist
right so i'm in the relationship where
every jump ball
goes to her and every and i can't even
say like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about because then like that's his abuse
gaslighting and abuse well then why but
okay i'm just thinking about why
do you have to pigeonhole yourself into
i gotta be the nice guy because
sometimes it feels like you're white
knuckling it
i am every time but because i don't
have to be because i there's not that
many nice nice nice guys like you're
explaining that's why sometimes
we differ fundamentally because it's
like there's a lot of [ __ ]
out there that don't yeah uh subscribe
to i have to do this
gotta treat it this hey you know these
are my standards is what i assure you i
would argue most guys when i hear about
other guys i'm like jesus
but you don't sometimes take that into
account when you
have an opinion about women all i can do
is talk from my own experience
right but you also are a really like
you're considered like a very nice guy
generous nice kind of can
like okay you're right this is the
standards i have for things you're right
i'm going to treat you like this even
though
you're being a dick or you're you have
the audacity to ask me to get my own
like these things and you still are like
you know i'm just going to choose to
still be the nice guy but you know most
guys aren't doing that
i agree i can never snap
i i will say this the next morning when
the girl left the show
uh-huh i broke up there oh she started
crying and was like i'm so sorry
you're right i was a total [ __ ] i was
like this is [ __ ]
better so you didn't so you didn't
actually break
i did and i broke up with her for like
90 seconds okay
and then she said i wouldn't take me
back and uh and you were like goddammit
you know what she hacked my emotions
she's a great guy and then i broke up
with her six weeks later okay
on on other charges
goodbye you've got um hey neil bianca
love the podcast youtube version on
thursday's a highlight for me i live in
germany with an american couple who are
mega supporters i got a job here
political scientist with a master's
degree in european foreign policy
and was looking for a place to live and
they were renting out the top floor of
their house
i thought it would be easier to live
with americans than germans since i'm
not german too
we would understand each other and there
would be no language issues to my
surprise after i moved in i realized
they are
non-stop watching fox news and tucker
carlson and so on
they're extremely racist uh
fancy that white people who moved to
germany
uh they even have blackface figurines on
the shelves they bought in new orleans
oh lord um
however their racism does not include me
because i'm a blonde
fair-skinned non-muslim turk i
don't see it like it sounds racist when
i say it like that
i find this inconsistency very weird
their racism seems to intensify when
one's skin color is darker
uh yep that's how it works uh they talk
to me all the time about how foreigners
are coming to germany and stealing jobs
as if
they themselves are not foreigners they
complain about socialist democrats in
the us
but they love the free healthcare in
germany they're full of such
inconsistent ideas
they even ask my opinion about usa
politics since i'm a political scientist
my question is do you and bianca think
that there's a way that i can
communicate with these people and point
out how ridiculous they're being
or do you think they're a loss calls is
there any way to communicate at this
point
uh movie's not an option um
uh i've decided to write to you after
neil's analogy about republicans and
democrats being like roommates who
cannot leave and must find a way to get
along
that was good every once in a while um
[Music]
yeah i don't i think i've been thinking
about
using the trick of going like i'm
interested in your thing
i want to be your thing but how about
this
wait what meaning saying like i'm open
to being conservative
okay but i don't under i can't figure
out a way to justify
being anti-socialism but
pro-pro medicine
or whatever anything yeah pro-free
medicine pro-medicare proper medicare
for all
how can you explain it to me in a way
that i can understand it
right and then let them lose
let me tell you something every time you
do that every time you give
always because i think people feel more
empowered fighting against
everybody but when you just give them a
floor
it's like when rick ingram would always
try to like sniff out trump supporters
in the audience
it's like what's your what's what's your
favorite policy of trump's
nothing yeah and it was always very
funny because that's a point and
everybody laughs
and they can't say muslim in the wall
yeah it's probably
it's just yeah that's what it is yeah
but uh
but yeah so it's it's muslim on the wall
it's coming this friday
on cbs premium platinum
um what um yeah no that's a good that's
a good tactic
yeah i've never done it but i've thought
about it as like i want to start doing
it
because my first instincts get mad
and then and want to yell then i'm like
no let's try to use some jiu-jitsu
and see what they say adam shift was on
frankenstein's podcast and he said
someone came up to him in the airport
he's like
a lot of feedback in the airport and he
goes the guy was like
hey this uh collusion stuff you can be
honest with me it's
it's [ __ ] right and and chef was
like well
imagine if hillary clinton
if chelsea got in an email uh
that said we have dirt on trump and this
is part of our campaign to help you
and he just laid it out as hillary and
the guy was like
yeah you're right everything is a time
to kill the closing argument
now imagine she was wise yeah you're
absolutely right
and it's and then it's like oh my god
what the buoyant
phil's glasses just fell off
uh yeah um also just
like yeah just try to try to engage
say like you i want to be i want to
follow your things
i can't figure out can you explain that
to me because it looks like
contradictory but maybe i'm seeing it
wrong
it's funny when she said that thing
about she the racism doesn't include her
when
uh i was getting bought out of a place a
long time ago and
for the last few months the landlord let
us airbnb
it and there was a lady she was older
white lady
who was coming to la to make it in
hollywood
she was 45 and she was from australia
thank you oscars i got another extra
thanks and so everything she said
was extremely racist but
10 degrees in the different hemisphere
like
latitude lattices longitude not black
people
she's like well hate like i don't just
hate the indian accent it's just so
terrible yeah and we
my friend me and my roommate who are
black women yeah
i just told her one night i'm like she
would hate
us but she just was born in a like a
different hemisphere
yeah it's just the local so i'm like the
local team
it's like the local team in the local
land i'm like run who are we for all
right before that
who are we against all right i can do
that yep when we say that we pretend
it's their accent
okay cool and they they're they're
against our way of life even though we
both live in houses next door to each
other
and we use the same septic system and
okay cool goodbye
um this is a good one you've got a ffa
neil bianca thanks for taking the time
to read my emails in the past it makes
the listeners more invested in your
podcast than others
shots fired don't know it who i'm in the
military and was the direct
supervisor of one of the first trans
soldiers in the army
uh he was treated very well and the
information was kept confidential to the
point that most people
thought he was a small guy and not
someone transitioning to mail
a small emotional man
uh i could go on and on and about how
well he was treated but i wanted to
address both of you asking why any trans
person would join the military
they pay for the transition it's got it
bang bada
all the hormones all the surgeries all
the mental health appointments all of it
i can't imagine how expensive years
worth of testosterone weekly therapy
and one of two surgeries would be uh or
one or two surgeries the
the person i knew joined the army as
female and left as a male
at zero cost i mean that's you want your
ads
right there oh weirdly weirdly
progressive for the army
yeah i that's yeah i think it's a bunch
of [ __ ]
i think it's like that and they're
beating up the trans
i think both happen in iran it's seen as
a mental health
condition and it's it's
free to transition it's like okay which
where do you want to go
yeah i mean you're trapped in your i
made the mistake of saying that it was a
mental health condition
on some podcast like 10 years ago and
that didn't go good
but so it is considered a mental health
condition it's basically like you're
born in the wrong body
choose which body you want to be in okay
cool let's go
the the the lady in the dale made me it
brought into sharper relief that
transitioning
is a nightmare i wouldn't wish wanting
to be
tr to the desire to transition i
wouldn't wish it on
my worst anime i would rather than watch
the ashton
i didn't it wasn't me commercial i would
truly rather
have i know it looks like it's just
awful
yeah um so our heart goes out to you
goodbye
uh hey binky in the brain and neil it
was interesting to listen to describe
how your panic attacks
this a guy this guy basically just said
that he thanked us for talking about
um mental health [ __ ] um
uh it's like you can't do it
he said the podcast has helped me
overcome my fear of treating
this disorder with drugs prescription
otherwise i'm still figuring out what
works but the process
is started and i have to thank you for
these occasional
good days nobody talks about mental
health
except for me and charlemagne
40 times more popular goodbye
uh been a feeler since day one throw the
youtube full up on that big screen and
work it out
i love that i like it kick [ __ ] out
[ __ ] kicking um this is a good one
i was surprised last podcast when binky
talked about daughters and fathers who
have never met
then they meet as adults and end up
hooking up i thought this was the case
uh i thought this was the case once in a
blue moon but guess not
i dated a girl both of us 32 and after a
year she told me a shocking story oh my
god why
she had sex with her biological father
she'd never met before
several times over a two-week trip to
finally meet him oh my god
i told him she told me she was 22 at the
time of the trip
they talked online many times before
hand and started flirting then
the night she met him they had sex she
said she bought
lingerie with her and his eyes were just
like hers
she she gave me more tmi than i needed
uh like she looked back on it fondly
oh my god um she said he had a daughter
from another marriage
just a little younger than her and they
they called each other sisters right
away
god knows what uh what that would have
how that would have went if she did not
tell her mother that day she got back
like they had even more in common you
can already tell
we are not dealing with the brightest
bulb and her mother called him
i guess she told the mom i would uh the
whole thing blew up and that's all she
said
um i tried to put it back put it in the
back of my mind we saw each other for
another year
after yeah you really have to be the
only one in the back if you want to keep
going
and broke up organically over her wanted
to get married and have kids that day
um have kids that day i was not wanting
kids till way down the road
um you also got to worry about of course
her [ __ ] the kids
um that's a big worry that you got it
uh and then this one it's called young
masturbation this is just another
section of his letter i had another
girlfriend uh that said it nine or ten
she was climbing a pole outside
somewhere on a playground and it
happened
she said she climbed that pole every day
for a long time
funny thing is later in life she became
a stripper crazy crazy world
um uh love you banks and the way you do
some hand and shoulder stretches during
the podcast it makes me do them with you
oh god uh p.s going to see tom segura in
west palm beach at the improv february
16th
florida just don't care but i'm taking
my fiji water to go
look guys don't promote other comedians
out there
we're not i don't want to hear about it
tom i don't want to hear about these
other bums uh
dude gross yeah creeping me
it's disgusting yeah i thank god i
had a very normal as a
child relationship with my dad because
i don't know the things i've read after
our after our uh
podcast i wanted to make sure that
wasn't nonsense and it's just it's like
a weird psychological thing
people love themselves of course they
want to [ __ ] them [ __ ] a version of
themselves
oh you think is that i thought it was i
think that's part of it i think it's
partially narcissism i think it's
partially like
why look for a father figure when you
can [ __ ]
the father itself why [ __ ] a metaphor
when you can [ __ ] the object like i
i'm personally not into it but
i get it really i don't even get it
advocate
no i just i just thought the way
families bond and connect when you don't
have that at a young age
that family bond becomes one way or the
other
okay we can do this the easy way or the
hard way oh it's so
the lingerie part's wild dude and uh
i just also stopped at the good part and
then the mom called the dad
yeah i mean but all the way also how do
you tell the mom like hey remember
richard turn that guy richard you dated
i [ __ ] him oh my god um
um so you know how i have daddy issues
okay i think they're either gonna get
way better or way worse
because i [ __ ] daddy um
goodbye you've got mail uh okay here's
one
okay greetings england banks thanks for
sharing all your stories about ayahuasca
i'm a 48 year old white guy in atlanta
and i've been curious for some time
atlanta and may have an opportunity in
the future to do to
try some ayahuasca when i come to la
i've talked about it at length with my
partner and she is hesitant her main
point is this
americans want a quick fix for
everything she understands the insights
that both of you are sharing
and how impactful it can be but she
questions whether or not you and others
are doing the work of deep diving into
your i found myself
doing deeper and deeper dives
i relate your experiences with uh what i
what i think has been lifelong therapy
nail and all the modalities and
medications you're on enough to share
with
us listeners she doesn't deny those
things but after watching one of the
recent unwell netflix episodes
about aya she further questions whether
i is being administered in ways that the
original shaman intended first of all
there's no original shaman
um and also i like how she says like
americans
these original there's no one original
shaman like
shaman jeff there's no i think she means
the
brown people right but they're also
they would like it to get be more
widespread the brown people
and i like how she's saying like they're
are they doing deep dives are the brown
people doing deep dives in the jungle
how what are they doing are they seeing
therapists are they
they doing uh they're doing what are
they doing there's
there's other points we can make what
i'm saying is no no
i'm she's saying that she's holding them
up as like
they're doing it the right way what are
they doing they're not doing anything
other than just
being in jungle people well also this
person doesn't want to do it and they're
finding yes to tell you that and they're
saying that you shouldn't do it either
here's the thing i'll say about
ayahuasca it's not easy
it's the did you listen to my [ __ ]
heart did you
could not he went to hell it is
it is very much akin to surgery
it's the the the recovery period yes
is so vital and it's so scary and it's
so important to actually
see results that she just doesn't know
what the [ __ ] she's talking about and
that's fine because i didn't know either
but i think if it's calling you it's not
calling you if it's calling you then
you have to do it and guess what is she
going to be mad at you for
trying to work on yourself like you need
to do that what work
some people are like that though they
they're they're intrigued
but they're like well no but they yeah
but you yeah damper because they're like
wow i don't know
why why it's like well why not
yes i just she doesn't want to do it
you're absolutely right she doesn't want
to do it she's being a hater she's being
hater
and um and uh and
it's you know the good news it's not
easy it's not an easy thing to do it we
made it sound
because especially me because the first
time was like
very joyous that it's like ecstasy or
something or mdma or molly or whatever
depending on how old you are um and uh
so i mean i don't want to say [ __ ] but
like whatever what ask her what work the
the natives are doing
in the the the people in the jungle the
shapibo trap what are they doing
[ __ ] i got news for you there's not
going to be an answer
and also that unwell thing they tried to
put a damper on it and all they could
find that
one bipolar guy did it and killed the
shaman
it's like yeah if your bipolar you can't
do it yeah so
it's otherwise it's been around for
thousands of years and
uh good and and
generate regenerates brain cells the
only thing in the world that does that
all just some people are get crabs in a
barrel
yeah they kind of are interested they
don't want you to try because then
they're gonna
yeah you gotta just do it and
the funny thing is whatever improvements
you have
can be you know evidence enough you
don't have to
also we don't need i don't we don't need
their support
yeah we don't need your girlfriend we're
eight miles
we're gonna rap y'all are nine mile
we're whatever we're rapping
regardless we're entering the rap
contest
regardless uh it's a quarter to
uh i don't have to say we don't have to
take this [ __ ]
so i hope you liked the podcast cause
it's now it's over
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
here
[Music]
bye